YOU COULD TELL DEFINITELY
GUNSHOTS.
>> Bret: SOME OF THE STUDENTS
WHO HAD TO DEAL WITH A HORRIBLE
SCENE.
17 DEAD.
STEVE HELTON AS A FORMER ADVISOR
TO DAVID CAMERON.
MARA LIASSON, NATIONAL POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT FOR NATIONAL
PUBLIC RADIO AND MATTHEW
CONTINUITY.
WE HAVE SEEN SO MANY OF THESE.
THERE IS SOMETHING OF A NUMBNESS
WHEN YOU HEAR IT HAPPENS BUT
THEN WHEN YOU ARE HIT BY THE
NUMBER, IT IS SHOCKING.
>> WHEN YOU LISTEN TO THE KIDS
TALK ABOUT WHAT THEY SAW, I HAVE
TALK ABOUT WHAT THEY SAW, I HAVI
TALK ABOUT WHAT THEY SAW, I HAVH
TALK ABOUT WHAT THEY SAW, I HAVV
TALK ABOUT WHAT THEY SAW, I HAVE
A MIDDLE SCHOOLER AND
HIGH SCHOOLER.
IT'S -- THEY'RE BEEN 12 SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS IN 2018.
WE HAVE HAD 45 DAYS OF 2018.
THIS HAPPENS TOO MUCH.
>> Bret: GETTING TO STOPPING
THIS, STEVE, IS A CONUNDRUM.
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN IN
GREAT BRITAIN THE FREQUENCY IT
HAS HERE.
IT HAPPENS BUT IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
IN THESE NUMBERS.
YOU HEARD SENATOR NELSON,
SENATOR RUBIO.
WAIT FOR THE FACTS.
SEE WHAT THE DEAL IS.
THERE'S A HUNGER TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE AS A COUNTRY
ARE GOING TO TACKLE THIS.
>> THERE IS.
AS MARA WAS SAYING, IT'S REALLY
HARD TO TAKE.
NO CHILD SHOULD HAVE TO SEE
THINGS LIKE THAT AND HAVE TO
RECOUNT THEM IN THE WAY WE JUST
HEARD.
OF COURSE THERE IS A NATURAL
HUMAN REACTION WHICH IS TO SAY
THERE MUST BE SOMETHING WE CAN
DO.
THERE MUST BE SOME POLICY OF
SOME KIND AND MAKE THIS NOT
HAPPEN.
THE BRITISH PERSPECTIVE FOR ME
IS, HAVING BEEN HERE SIX YEARS
IN AMERICA, AND LIVED HERE AND
UNDERSTOOD THINGS I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHEN I LIVED IN THE
U.K., YES, IT'S TRUE THAT IN
COUNTRIES LIKE THE U.K. THEY
LOOK AT THIS AND SAY WHAT'S THE
MATTER WITH THEM?
WHY DOES THIS KEEP HAPPENING?
WHY CAN'T THEY SORT IT OUT?
NOW THAT I'M HERE, I UNDERSTAND
IT'S NOT AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
THERE'S A HERITAGE AND CULTURE
AND HISTORY HERE.
SOME SOLUTIONS THAT MAY SEEM
OBVIOUS IN OTHER COUNTRIES ARE
NOT OBVIOUS HERE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT WHEN
WE SEE SOMETHING LIKE THIS,
FOCUSING ALL OF OUR ATTENTION,
THESE MASS SHOOTINGS.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE WHO DIED FROM
GUN VIOLENCE IN AMERICA DON'T
DIE IN THESE SITUATIONS.
THEY DIED ONCE AND NEVER GET
ATTENTION.
I THINK THE IDEA THAT THERE IS A
SIMPLE SOLUTION IS JUST NOT
TRUE.
>> Bret: FOR EXAMPLE, THE
NUMBERS OUT OF CHICAGO DAY TODAY
ARE STAGGERING.
WE COVER THEM HERE BUT IN THIS
SITUATION, THESE MASS SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS, IT DOES NOT APPEAR
THIS GUY HAS A TERRORIST TIE.
WE DON'T KNOW.
HE'S BEEN EXPELLED FOR
DISCIPLINARY ACTION, SEEMED LIKE
A TROUBLED STUDENT WHO WAS
TALKING ABOUT GUNS AND BOMBS
BEFORE.
>> HE WAS BORN IN 1998, A FEW
MONTHS BEFORE COLUMBINE.
REALLY KIND OF INAUGURATED THIS
HISTORICAL EPIC OF SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS.
WE ARE COMING UP ALMOST ON THE
20TH ANNIVERSARY OF COLUMBINE IN
1999.
IT'S BEEN A GENERATION.
YOU SEE THE PREPARATION THAT
GOES INTO NOT ONLY THE
AUTHORITIES BUT ALMOST THE
STUDENTS.
THE WAY THEY WERE DESCRIBING
THEIR EXPERIENCE.
SOME WERE CLEARLY EMOTIONALLY
RATTLED.
OTHERS WERE DESCRIBING IT
BECAUSE THEY ARE KIND OF USED TO
THE PROCEDURES.
IT'S BECOME KIND OF A WAY OF
LIFE WHICH I DON'T THINK ANYONE
COUNTED ON WHEN COLUMBINE
HAPPENED.
ANOTHER X FACTOR'S SOCIAL MEDIA.
WHEN COLUMBINE HAPPENED, WE HAD
CABLE NEWS AND 24-HOUR COVERAGE.
NOW WE HAVE REAL-TIME ACCOUNTS
FROM STUDENTS THEMSELVES.
ON THE ONE HAND, THAT GIVES US A
PERSPECTIVE ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENING.
ON THE OTHER IT MEANS SOMETIMES
MISINFORMATION AND RUMOR CAN GET
INVOLVED.
WE ARE LIVING IN THIS ERA BUT
THERE HAVE BEEN NEW CHANGES I
THINK THAT MAKE IT ALL THE MORE
VISCERAL TO US.
>> Bret: OUR JOB IS TO COVER
IT.
WE DON'T WANT TO MAKE THIS GUY A
STAR, BUT THIS IS A MAJOR EVENT
IN U.S. NEWS AT THIS MOMENT AND
FRANKLY THIS YEAR.
MARA, WHAT DO YOU THINK, AS WE
DO THIS EVERY TIME, WHAT DO YOU
THINK COMES OUT OF THIS?
>> WELL, WE HAVE CERTAINLY
LEARNED NOT TO PREDICT ANY KIND
OF LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION IS GOING
TO COME OUT OF THIS.
IT DIDN'T COME OUT OF NEWTOWN
WHERE SEVERAL DOZEN KIDS WERE
GUNNED DOWN.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A SIMPLE
SOLUTION BUT I THINK THERE ARE
SOME THINGS YOU COULD DO TO MAKE
THESE LESS FREQUENT.
TO MAKE GUN DEATHS IN GENERAL
LESS FREQUENT.
WHY DO PEOPLE ON A TERRORIST
WATCH LIST STILL ALLOWED TO BUY
GUNS.
ISN'T THERE A BETTER SYSTEM FOR
FLAGGING MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY WOULD BE
BUT IT SEEMS THERE ARE SOME
SIMPLE THINGS, MAYBE NOT WAVE A
MAGIC WAND, BUT THIS SHOULDN'T
HAPPEN THIS OFTEN PERIOD.
I DON'T CARE IF WE LIVE IN A
COUNTRY THAT HAS A STRONG, PROUD
HERITAGE OF OWNING FIREARMS.
THIS SHOULDN'T HAPPEN THIS OFTEN
THIS SHOULDN'T HAPPEN THIS OFTE
OFTEN.
>> Bret: THAT WE CAN SAY
DEFINITIVELY.
>> THERE MUST BE WAYS WE CAN
MAKE IT LESS HAPPEN LESS
FREQUENTLY.
>> Bret: THERE ARE 535
LAWMAKERS BEHIND ME IN THAT
BUILDING.
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF TIME OVER THE
YEARS.
WHY DO YOU THINK -- IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE A GUN POLICY ISSUE?
COULDN'T BE A MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE?
>> AND WE HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS
AFTER THESE HORRIFIC EVENTS,
THAT PHRASE COMES UP A LOT.
MENTAL HEALTH.
I THINK WE NEED TO GO DEEPER
THAN THAT BECAUSE THERE'S A
SENSE OF SOCIAL BREAKDOWN NOT
JUST IN AMERICA.
I DON'T WANT TO MAKE IT AMERICAN
BUT YOU SEE IT IN COUNTRIES, WE
SOUGHT IN THE U.K. WHEN I WORKED
IN GOVERNMENT THERE AND IT WAS
ONE OF THE THINGS WE TRIED TO
ADDRESS AND IT COMES BACK TO
THINGS LIKE THE DISINTEGRATION
OF THE FAMILY.
PEOPLE NOT GROWING UP IN STABLE,
LOVING HOMES.
ALL THE OTHER ISSUES WE DEAL
WITH PIECEMEAL.
THEY GO BACK TO THAT NOTION OF
STABILITY IN THE FAMILY HOME,
AND THAT IS SOMETHING GOVERNMENT
CAN HELP ADDRESS.
I DON'T SEE ANY SIGN OF THE KIND
OF FOCUS WE NEED ON HELPING MAKE
SURE EVERY CHILD IN THIS COUNTRY
GROWS UP IN A STABLE, LOVING
HOME.
THAT CERTAINLY WOULD HELP WITH
THIS.
>> Bret: IN THE SHORT-TERM
TONIGHT WE ALL GRIEVE FOR 17
FAMILIES WHO WILL NOT HAVE THEIR
KIDS COMING HOME.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE ALL
KIDS OR TEACHERS AND KIDS BUT 17
FAMILIES WILL NOT HAVE LOVED
ONES COMING HOME TONIGHT.
AND THAT IS STUNNING.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS WE'VE SEEN
AFTER THESE EVENTS IF YOU PLOT
LEGISLATION PASSED ON THE STATE
LEVEL AND ELSEWHERE, WHAT
HAPPENS IS GUN LAWS GET
LOOSENED.
IT GETS EASIER TO BUY GUNS,
EASIER TO CARRY THEM OPENLY.
>> Bret: THE ARGUMENT IS IF IT
WAS A SECURITY OFFICER WITH THE
GUN, COULD'VE STOPPED.
IT'S AN ARGUMENT.
>> THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
LEGISLATION THAT'S BEEN PASSED.
WHY?
ONE OF THE REASONS AND YOU CAN'T
IGNORE IT IS THERE IS AN
EXTERNALLY POWERFUL LOBBY IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT DOESN'T WANT
ANY OF THESE LAWS PASSED.
>> A LOBBY THAT IS VERY
EFFECTIVE AT ELECTING
REPRESENTATIVES.
MAINLY BECAUSE IT ENJOYS PUBLIC
SUPPORT.
ONE OF THE PARADOXES OF THE
COLUMBINE ERA IS THAT EVEN AS WE
SEE THESE HIGHLY NOTED,
SENSATIONAL, MASS EVENTS THAT
ARE HORRIFYING, THE POLITICS OF
GUN CONTROL HAVE SHIFTED RIGHT.
IT AND SO HOW ONE ADDRESSES THE
SITUATION IS A MYSTERY.
IT'S NOT JUST GUN-CONTROL.
ITS PRIVACY CONCERNS CONCERNS.
THE SHERIFF MENTIONED "SEE
SOMETHING, SAY SOMETHING."
LOOK AT SOCIAL MEDIA.
I AM SURE THAT THE WIZARDS OF
SILICON VALLEY EVENTUALLY WILL
DEVELOP A PROGRAM THAT WILL BE
ABLE TO APPEAL THROUGH SOCIAL
MEDIA AND DETERMINE WHO IS MOST
LIKELY TO COMMIT CRIMES SUCH AS
THIS.
>> Bret: WE RUN INTO PRIVACY
CONCERNS FROM PEOPLE WHO SAY
THIS IS BIG BROTHER LOOKING INTO
MY LIFE.
>> THE CULTURE MAKES IT HARD FOR
US TO ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS
POLITICALLY.
>> THERE WAS A TIME WHEN CERTAIN
KINDS OF SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPONS
WERE BANNED IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT BAN EXPIRED AND IT'S BEEN
IMPOSSIBLE TO REINSTATE IT.
NONE OF THESE SHOOTINGS WOULD
HAVE A NUMBER OF FATALITIES.
SOME PEOPLE WOULD BE KILLED.
NOT AS MANY.
>> Bret: HOLD ON.
LET'S STAY CLEAR TO WHAT WE KNOW
LET'S STAY CLEAR TO WHAT WE KNO
KNOW.
HE HAD AN AR-15.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE HE GOT THE
GUN.
PEOPLE SAY IF HE DIDN'T HAVE THE
GUN, HE WOULD HAVE A BOMB AND HE
WOULD PLANT THE BOMB.
>> WE HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF
SCHOOL BOMBINGS.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW WHAT I AM
SAYING.
>> I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR INSTANCE BUT THERE
WAS A TIME WHEN WE BANNED
ASSAULT WEAPONS.
>> Bret: LAST WORD, STEVE.
>> I THINK THERE IS SOMETHING
THAT CAN BE DONE BUT IT HAS TO
BE DEEP AND LONG TERM AND
ADDRESS THE SOCIAL CAUSES, NOT
JUST THE SYMPTOMS.
IF THIS TOWN GOES ALL IN FOR
TRYING TO FIND A GUN RELATED
SOLUTION TO THIS, IT'S NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN.
SOMETHING USEFUL THAT COULD COME
OUT OF IT IS REAL ACTION AROUND